In the last video we started
off with two linear
transformations.
We had the linear transformation
s that was a
mapping from Rn to Rm.
And then we had the linear
transformation t, that was
also a mapping from Rn to Rm.
And we defined the idea of
the addition of these two
transformations.
So s plus t, this transformation
of x we defined
as being equal to s of x,
this vector plus t of x.
And of course, this input is
still from Rn, and then each
of these are vectors in Rm.
If we add two vectors in Rm to
each other, we get another
vector in Rm because Rm
is a valid subspace.
It's also closed
under addition.
So this is still a mapping.
So s plus t is still a mapping
from Rn to Rm.
And we also said that every
linear transformation we've
shown in a previous video, can
be represented as a matrix.
We could say that s of
x is equal to some
matrix a times x.
And we could also say that
t of x is equal to some
matrix b times x.
And both of these would
be m by n matrices.
And let me write that m
by n, both of these.
Because these are both mappings
from Rn to Rm.
And what we did is we made
a another definition.
This was a definition right here
and then we made another
definition.
We defined the addition
of two matrices.
We said any matrix a plus b,
they both have to have the
same dimensions.
So they're both m by
n in this case.
And we defined this addition to
be a new matrix, where each
column of this matrix is the
sum of the corresponding
columns of these matrices.
So this matrix's first column
will be the sum of a's first
column and b's first column.
So a1 plus b1, the second column
I'll do a little line
here is, a2 plus b2.
And it goes all the
way to An plus Bn.
This was a definition.
And the whole reason why we
made this definition, is
because if you defined matrix
addition in this way, then
this thing, when you replace it
with Ax plus Bx, you get to
that this thing over here is
equal to the corresponding
matrices by this definition,
a plus b times x.
This was the motivation to get
to a nice expression, like
this, for defining matrix
addition in this way.
Now this all seems very
abstract, so let's actually
add a matrix, or let's
add two matrices.
So we'll start off with
a two-by-two case.
So let's say I'm adding the
matrix 1, 3, minus 2, 4 to the
matrix, remember they have to
have the same dimensions, to
the matrix 2, 7, minus
3, minus 1.
What do we get?
Well by definition, you
just add up their
corresponding columns.
You add up the first column.
When you add up the
corresponding columns, what
happens when you add up two
columns, two vectors?
Well, you just add up their
corresponding entries.
So essentially, when you add
up to matrices, you're just
adding up all of the
corresponding entries.
I'll talk about it in this way,
just because that's how I
defined it, but they're
all equivalent.
The first thing, the first
column, in this matrix right
here, is going to be this
column plus this column.
So it's going to be 1 plus 2,
let me write it like this, and
then minus 2, minus 3.
And then the second column, that
one right there, is going
to be 3 plus 7 and
then 4 minus 1.
And so this will be equal
to 3, 10, minus 5, and
3, just like that.
And notice, even though the
definition is I'm adding up
corresponding columns.
Well, what in effect happened?
Well, I'm just adding up the
corresponding entries.
I added the 1 to the 2, the 3
to the 7, the minus 2 to the
minus 3, the 4 to the minus 1.
It's that straightforward.
Nothing fancier than that.
In fact, we could have rewritten
this definition.
If we say that the vector or the
matrix a is equal to a11
a12, all the way to a1n.
And then if you go down this
is a21 all the way to a1n.
And then you go all the
way down there to ann.
We've seen that before.
And then the matrix b, just
by the same argument or by
similar definition, this is b11,
that entry is b11, that's
b12, all the way to b1n.
This is b21, second row, all the
way down to bn, sorry this
is m, we have m rows,
so this is mn.
So this right here is bm1, this
would be bm2, all the way
down to this is bmn,
right there.
Want to be very careful, these
are m by n matrices.
So this row down here is the
mth row in both cases.
But we could redefine our
matrix, or another way of
stating this matrix addition
definition, is to say, if I'm
going to add a plus b, I'm
just going to add up the
corresponding entries.
So this entry up here is going
to be-- do it in a different
color --it's going to be a11
plus b11 this one's going to
be a21 plus b21 all the way
down to am1 plus bm1.
And then this is going to be,
of course, a12 plus b12 all
the way to a1n-- let me scroll
over a little bit --all the
way over to a1n plus b1n,
and then all the way
down to amn plus bmn.
These are equivalent
definitions.
This takes a lot less space
to write in and I felt
comfortable doing it because
we've already
defined vector addition.
But it essentially boils down
to you just add up all the
corresponding entries.
That's all matrix addition is.
It's probably one of the
simplest things that you've
seen in your recent mathematical
experience.
Now, matrix scalar
multiplication,
very similar idea.
We defined scalar multiplication
times a
transformation of x to be equal
to a scalar times the
transformation of x.
This was a definition.
And we also defined scalar
times some matrix a to be
equal to the scalar.
A new matrix where each of its
columns are the scalar times
the column vectors of a.
So a1, and then the next column
is ca2, and then you go
all the way to can.
And the whole motivation for
this was, because this could
be simplified to-- well t I've
said was equal to Bx, a times
the transformation of x
--the transformation t
of x was equal to.
So we still have our c.
So it's going to be c
times the matrix B,
times the vector x.
That's what the transformation
of x could be written as.
And so this would be equal to by
just manipulating-- and we
did this in the last video by
actually breaking this up in
the column vectors multiplying
them by each of the components
of x, and then distributing the
c and rearranging them a
little bit.
We can now say, using this
definition, that this is equal
to some new matrix cB.
We're using this definition,
some new matrix cB, where it's
essentially c times
each of the column
vectors of B times x.
This right here was
our motivation.
We wanted to be able express
this as a product of some new
matrix and a vector, because
any linear transformation
should be expressible
in that way.
And that's why we made
this definition.
Now let's apply it.
And I wanted to show you that
this is perhaps even simpler
than matrix addition.
So if we want to multiply the
scalar 5 times the matrix,
I'll do a 3 by 2 matrix.
So 1, minus 1, 2, 3, 7, 0.
This will just be equal to--
by this definition I'm just
saying, I'm multiplying the
scalar times each of the
column vectors.
So it's 5 times 1, 2, 7.
But what's that?
That's just 5 times each
of the entries.
It's 5 times 1, which is 5.
5 times 2, which is 10.
5 times 7, which is 35.
Then the next column is going
to be 5 times this column
right here, which is just 5
times each of its entries.
So 5 times minus 1 is minus 5.
5 times 3 is 15.
5 times 0 is 0.
It's that simple.
You literally, if we go back
to this definition, we can
define scalar multiplication
of a matrix.
So we could also define cA as
being equal to, if we'd say
this is a representation for A,
of the scalar c times each
of the entries of A.
That's it.
So it's c times a11,
c times a12 all the
way to c times a1n.
You go down this way, c times
a21 all the way down to c
times am1 and then if you
go down the diagonal,
it's be c times amn.
You literally just take your
scalar and multiply it times
every entry in A.
And that's all you have to do.
So hopefully this clarified
things up a little bit, or
maybe it was a bit of a review
from things you might have
learned in highschool.